Oh what is going on YouTube you know a
lot of us today are on a ton of social
media facets such as Bookface Twatter
tumblr door and mammogram doesn't those
that's not it but what a particular has
been on my list of interests and that's
your Facebook status updates oh and I
really got big in some of the stuff that
y'all put up and updates or just got
there so you already know what it is LG
awesome baby let's get number one [ __ ]
don't Facebook updates let me tell you
something nobody cares what's going on
in your life every 10 seconds I'm eating
food I'm chewing food
I'm [ __ ] food Oh B I just don't
wanna care about Joe Carroll circle of
life [ __ ] I got two other friends I'm
trying to face with stuff and you are
making it difficult for me number two
why are you using Facebook to post about
real problems hmm there is some real
[ __ ] that you are Facebook posting about
that you should not be doing for example
why you Facebook updating about a crime
that is happening right now oh my god
I'm witnessing or raping what do I do
call the [ __ ] police you
decided to go ahead and facebook status
update the situation instead of
comic-con
hmm let me ask you something stupid did
you ask them to stop so what you can
Instagram them first
hold still for a second try to get the
right filter number three stop posting
up [ __ ] so people can compliment your
sorry ass oh my good oh look here blow
fina we all know why did you do that
[ __ ] is because you want all your guy
friends to read you comments and thumbs
up your status update no you're a sacred
beautiful jasmine flower one word to
describe you
peebo a word mr. ghetto Shakespeare a
few words to Scott yo ass corny ass you
guys are the sorriest creatures on earth
somebody gasping is these guys actually
think that if they leave that compliment
just maybe she'll remember and look my
way [ __ ]
the closer you are ever gonna touch it
is probably in your dreams with Papa
Henderson and Angela Johnson number four
stop posting up pictures of food that
you just made why you ask because they
look like [ __ ] I'm not talking about you
making a delicious and intricate meal
I'm talking about you making a damn
sandwich and type in look what I made
it's a sandwich [ __ ] what you want a
cookie and more importantly stop posting
the pictures of food if you can't cook
just because you type homemade in front
of that [ __ ] does not mean it looks or
even tastes good you know what else is
homemade do keep it from the looks of it
yo [ __ ] look just like that last but not
least number five stop posting up song
lyrics ladies do you know what I
supposed of lyrics on the Facebook steps
updates it's just so we can show you
that we have a sensitive time and about
90% of your Facebook status updates on
Drake lyrics a drink I've said this
before I've said this again [ __ ]
I hate your guts
you honestly had the darkest eyebrows on
earth that [ __ ] look like two lines of
straight gunpowder on your face I don't
hate you drink cuz obviously you doing
something right because everybody quotes
you [ __ ] I hate your guts but I
swear to God is somebody else folks but
thankee another man you know I'll be
over there
i'ma shave your [ __ ] eyebrows
off oh I'll do it if I can find him Oh
check it out what is going on so
important announcement I'm gonna be at
Honolulu collaboration that's right and
it's going down on the 18th so if y'all
are in the area and Honolulu you know in
the Hawaiian island area
check me out it's gonna be a dope ass
show there's me some other performers
coming out description and stuff is
gonna be on the link my information
might be incorrect I don't know but
check out the description in the links
below on the on the show more
information part you know the part that
you guys never look at but anyways check
me out it's gonna be dope it's gonna be
real fun so I hope see y'all there and
this is like the beginning to a softcore
porn that no way would buy